[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
uh John Smoltz said to join us John was
on the call last night he'll be on the
call again tonight Johnny joining us uh
from a golf course here and uh kind
enough to join us uh John let me start
with Dusty Baker goes out and takes out
his pitcher uh can you plead your case
that you want to stay in into the game
you you
allowing the guy to have a feel for the
game in that point to get himself out of
that game either take him out much
earlier but once it got Bases Loaded
that's a very difficult spot to put
anybody in I don't care if a reliever
has never given up a run you come in
with a basis load and no room for error
it was almost as if they anticipated
that Pena was going to bunt then they
were going to bring in Alvarado but
every move has worked so far for Philly
it's hard to kind of criticize some of
the moves but last night was an
impossible situation for one of their
best pitchers was that a no-hitter
uh it was it wasn't the no-hitter that
um you know Don Drysdale pitched by any
means and his was a perfect game but you
know anytime you do something that is
very difficult whether it's five
pitchers or two pitchers it's a pretty
incredible feat at this time of the year
you know
nobody had shut down the Philadelphia
lineup nobody no starting pitcher no
Collective staff and this was uh this
was much needed for Houston if they were
going to win the series they had to kind
of punch the boys that were uh making uh
a mockery of all the starting pitching
at home you mentioned I think Don
Drysdale Don Larson through the uh Don
Larson through the perfect game but you
start to look at this is this just a
one-off Kyle schwarber said I don't care
if we got no hit we lost a game but how
big of a loss is this or how big of a
win is this for the Astros I think it's
a bigger win for the Astros they have
more depth and they're more confident in
their ability to pitch because they've
done that all year uh for the Phillies
just another loss that's exactly what I
would say whether you you know it's
sometimes better to lose this way than
lose by one run every time you get in a
situation where you could answer a
question like what if this would have
happened so I think for really the
Phillies no big deal they've got a tough
test today and if they get back on their
offensive game plan and take Fair take
care of mistakes they'll be up 3-2 going
in but they're in a tough one when it
comes to uh Justin Verlander being able
to make adjustments from game to game
but how does he make that adjustment he
didn't look good at all he's never won a
World Series game
what are the adjustments like what's
different for Justin Verlander
the biggest thing is I think you'll
realize mechanically what he has to do
after those first nine he got out he was
on point he was exposing the weaknesses
of the Philly offense and then whatever
the delay or whatever happened he got
out of his mechanics in my opinion lost
the command of his fastball we saw last
night when a man has his fastball going
like Javier did it's very difficult to
hit and Justin has the same capability
with that four seam fastball to expose
the weaknesses of any hitter he did it
perfectly for nine innings sometimes you
can be too passionate want it too much
I'm not saying that he fell into that
category but when you have a five
nothing lead that's a great feeling to
have and the next thing you know
you're in a tight game and you're
answering the same questions so I'm sure
he'll be paying attention to those
details because Justin Verlander is one
of the best
was Lance McCullers tipping his pitches
I think there was a I think there was a
portion of which he was tipping I don't
think it's where everybody was making it
out there's a lot of experts at home
they can freeze their TV see things that
they think they're seeing but the
reality is out of the stretch with the
glove that's possibly the way that you
can eliminate if you can eliminate one
pitching one pitch at a time or one
pitch in a repertoire you've got a huge
Advantage let's be honest and I think he
said it well he left a lot of pitches in
his Zone even if you know it's coming
and you execute your pitch you're going
to get out he struck out Five Guys he
got nine or eight in a row out of the
wind-up so I would say that out of the
stretch yes there was a probably with
the glove that's the common uh fault of
a pitcher is you you tilt your glove one
way or another once you know one piss
you can eliminate the other and I think
there was no doubt that they were
sitting on pitches and let's let's be
honest the other thing with this pitch
selection when you don't throw a
fastball to a left-hander or one you you
can eliminate it and I think if he
pitches again he has to change and have
confidence in his fastball because he's
a dynamic pitcher that loves the moment
and it's a one-off for him so he got
into a little bit of a funk how does
this play out John
well you know what I think the biggest
thing that these teams have been able to
show is punch counter punch I think the
team that wins two in a row is going to
win it I mean that sounds corny but
nobody has lost two in a row in about 30
games or 25 games this this Advantage
always has been a little bit given to
the Houston Astros once the rain out
happened you can make the argument that
Philly closed the Gap because they could
use pitchers differently but the team
that is the most patient or allows their
starter to go a little bit deeper now is
going to have an advantage on not
running those guys out all the time the
more you see relievers in a postseason
the better it is for the offense the
less you see them and the more you can
use high leverage the better it is for
that team where are you playing golf
today
Monarch I think I'm saying it right this
is where the first PGA stroke play
Championship happened so there's a
little bit of History here greens are
great I'm having a time in my life
because I never thought I'd get this
kind of weather in the postseason you
know it's a good pregame ritual get my
golf in stay locked in and enjoy the
great seat that I have in the booth but
did you play golf before a start in in
any playoff game
not a start but I did play golf on the
road in the World Series in the playoffs
I didn't change any of my routines uh
when it was in between and if I was a
closer once I was for three years yes I
did play Golf the day of the game
because you don't know if you're going
to get in and if I can't get three outs
at 10 o'clock at night then something's
wrong
great to talk to you again John thank
you all right thanks Dad Johnny Smoltz
World Series champion he's on the call
for tonight's game game five pivotal
between the Astros and Phillies that's
uh eight Eastern on Fox